can non-technical people apply there you
think of course right every technical
company definitely needs people that are
in non-technical roles whether it's
again marketing community sales whatever
whatever whatever the rules will end up
being
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be what i want to
i put my all in it like no days off on
the road let's travel never looking back
okay um this episode is gonna be awesome
and then the there's a story behind this
i don't know if i told you this story
sean but basically my wife sarah
she about four or five years ago so my
wife is like pretty type a went to an
ivy league school isn't particularly
risk doesn't like taking risks doesn't
want like she she's someone who's going
to rise up in a in a big company and be
an executive one day and she wanted to
she was like i want to join a new
company and i want to make a lot of
money and she was uh sarah's uh
gonna be 29 uh next week so she was what
25 and she said i want to join a company
where i can make some money so we made a
list of a bunch of companies where we
thought if she was given let's say 250
000 of stock that would invest over four
years we made lists of places where that
stock could like 10x
and
that's how she eventually she applied
and got a job at airbnb that was like
five years ago and now they're i think
when she joined
what was their last valuation before
they went public like 18 or 20 billion i
think and now their valuation is like
100 i think so uh it what's that 5x
maybe so it did okay
and
we and you and i were talking and i
think you're underplaying it it did
better than okay let's just frame this
this fully right so
joined a multi-billion dollar company
that already had 3 000 something
employees no it wasn't that big i think
it had 1200 but yes it was big all right
so over a thousand employees so uh
you know not joining a risky startup not
buying a lottery ticket
and uh so she knew this is going to have
some gain it's just a question of like
some value it's just a question of how
much
got a job and she wasn't like an exec so
it was kind of like an achievable thing
like she came in as like yeah i don't
know like a mid-level manager is that
fair to say
mid-level yeah i would say yeah lower
low like lower to mid
right lower to mid so it didn't even
come in as a hot shot
and before the age of 30
was worth it was a multi-millionaire
because of
the stock that that appreciated from
this thing right from from from joining
airbnb right so self-made
multi-millionaire stuff self-made
multi-millionaire without eating as
a startup founder right right where
you're stressed and you're making no
money and you might fail all the time
and all that stuff and you have to make
payroll and all that good stuff
and um you know so so had to kind of
like cushy you know every day got to go
in and pick which flavor of soy milk she
liked from the company fridge and like
had health benefits and had all the
things that you get the good things you
get at a company plus got to see it grow
right so so i thought by the way i am i
i cannot confirm or deny the
multi-million dollar i i i i can't
completely blow up her spot or the the
soy milk spot shouldn't drink soy milk
but the point is the point is is that
airbnb was like they they pay come very
competi you know they recruit people
from google and facebook so they pay
competitive salary you get very
competitive and wonderful benefits you
work really hard but it's not a startup
of 20 people where you don't have any
resources you know you have resources to
to get help and so the idea with this
we're calling this sarah's list we
should come up with a cuter name one day
but it's the idea here is that we made a
list of companies that
are
cushier than like a 20-person startup
but still have wonderful upside so you
can make a very competitive salary have
wonderful benefits and there's like a 5
10 15 x upside so low risk
great reward you're not going to become
a billionaire doing this that's okay
most people don't really care about that
so when i heard this when we were
talking i was like oh wow like
um
i think of myself as the hustler but
this is the ultimate hustle right you
know not in a bad way what i mean was
like this was the hack this was the
lowest low effort low risk
way to get a great outcome meaning
didn't have to work 120 hours a week
didn't have to like carry the whole
company on their back didn't have to
like pick a winner uh and it's really
hard to pick early stage winners it's
like no pretty clearly he was going to
be a winner and still walked away with a
great outcome or you know still had a
great great outcome so i thought wow
that's that's actually fantastic i think
there's a lot of people who would love
that path there's some people who want
to be elon musk they want to go change
the world there's some people who want
to make a billion dollars there's some
people who want to just have go sit on a
beach and do nothing right but but
there's a lot of people who would love
this hey let me work at a great company
with really smart people working on a
cool product and let me build you know
uh you know financial independence
without risking it all like you know
like a degenerate gambler so to me we
got craigslist we got angie's list
what's the one with the child predators
i don't know what that one's called like
molly's list or something like that we
got whatever molly's list and now we
have sarah's list and sarah's list is
the companies that we think you could go
join today they're already valued you
know over 250 million dollars um
they have we think a low risk profile
but if you stayed there for four years
and you came in as a mid-level person
and you got your grants which is like 50
000 in stock every year or something
like that
that that could make you a self-made
millionaire or multi-millionaire that's
the that's the thing
before we get into this everything that
we're gonna say it's not like financial
advice or anything all the information
that we have it's basically what we've
just read online or rumors that we've
heard amongst friends none of it
so like everything is hearsay and a lot
of predictions right yes yeah we could
be wrong but that we thought it'd be fun
you know like we're not going to go take
these jobs but there's a lot of people
out there who would love to know hey
what would you all recommend we know
it's not a guarantee we know it's not
set in stone we know this is just a
prediction but hey some prediction is
better than nothing so we'll go on the
record and we'll see how these play out
all right so we each did a research we
got five
yeah so you go so we have five i got
more than five but let's go you go i go
and then we'll go back and forth okay
great um okay i'm gonna save my best one
i'm gonna bring in second i'm gonna
first jab just feel fill you out see how
strong you're coming in but my best one
is coming next my power punch is coming
second okay but for for the first one my
first one that i'm gonna present for
sarah's list my my nomination
is
flexport
okay okay what's flexport so flexport is
a company that you use
when you are
when you are shipping things so you so
for example my e-commerce company we
ship things we need to arrange between
an international supplier we need our
goods to go from their factory to our
our warehouse well how do you do that
you gotta you gotta go to a bunch of uh
shipping carriers you gotta say hey when
are you when do you have a boat leaving
my my ready date is august third do you
have a boat august third what's the
price they get some quotes so what
flexport does this is a job called
freight forwarding flexport is basically
software that does this thing that used
to be done pretty manually or with very
old clunky software they made modern
slick software that does this freight
forwarding thing right so you go online
you can see all your quotes you book
your boat with a simple click you pay
the fees it's all you know like very
nice and then the notifications come
through and basically it is modern
freight forwarding software so
flexport's currently valued last public
valuation was about three billion
dollars
um the softbank put in a billion dollars
at a three point
uh 3.2 billion dollar valuation it's got
about 2 500 employees these are abouts
so you know about 2500 employees and
they're in a huge space so global
shipping is is massive it's only getting
bigger the bigger ecommerce gets
and um
and what they did was there was all
these small mom and pop freight
forwarders and they just sort of like
did what many great companies do they
they sort of take a fragmented market
with low nps and they build a
best-in-class product that's you know
integrated and so you don't have to deal
with kind of the the mom and pop
telephone call game that you would have
otherwise had to do and the founder is
pretty amazing zayn's is ryan peterson
i've hung out with him once or twice and
i've read a lot of interviews with him
he's very charismatic he once said that
uh this company's either gonna be worth
zero or a hundred billion dollars or
something like that you know he's like
this is gonna be all or nothing right
and he's pretty he's very very good we
should compile an ebook of quotes like
that that's like talk dirty to me the vc
edition it's like what are some offhand
things you can say as a founder that
just get every investor to like salivate
and they they sometimes sound dumb like
why would i say my company's either
gonna be worth zero or a hundred billion
it's like but that's exactly what a vc
wants because that's how their economics
work so we should just and you could
just cherry-pick these phrases they're
like pick-up lines for vcs and uh and we
should just make a little e-book out of
those but that's a good one
all right um next one uh i'm gonna go
first mine will be easy as well zapier
uh so what they do
it's always really hard for me to
explain what this company does but once
you use it you immediately get it and
i'll give you a use case so basically
what they do is they connect apis so for
example when the hustle first started we
had we didn't i didn't want to buy like
greenhouse or one of these like really
500 a month applicant tracking systems
and so i created a google form and then
i use zapier to connect that to asana
and so every time someone applied to a
job the information was automatically
film filled into an asana board and
that's what we use to track our job
applicants another example and this is
like a really simple personal use case
is i had a scale and every time i
stepped on my smart scale
it told zapier and zapier put my weight
into a spreadsheet and i compared it to
all my friend's weight and we had a
competition now that's like a really
simple use case but they do incredibly
complicated ones where they'll attach
loads of different so you could build an
entire company
using
basically google spreadsheets and zapier
um they're interesting for a few reasons
first
they bootstrapped it to like 60 to 70
million dollars in recurring revenue and
they did it very quickly they recently
raised a little bit of funding at a 5
billion valuation by uh i believe
sequoia they currently have 350 people
um my opinion is this is going to end up
very similar to atlassian so atlassian
is an australian company that went
public i think in 2014
and when they went public it was like a
15 or no maybe it was like a six billion
dollar valuation and they sold uh
widgets to small businesses software to
small businesses and people slept on
them and it slowly scaled i think today
at blasting is worth 100 billion dollars
i think zapier is gonna be similar wade
foster the founder of zapier spoke at
hustlecon and i hung out with him and he
was like everything i he was just like
perfect he was wonderful
there is one downside i've heard through
friends of friends that they don't they
so their pay is they they're a remote
team they've been remote from day one
they don't they pay against chicago
market salaries so they don't pay san
francisco salaries so that might be a
downside but i would love to own zapier
stock
yeah okay so so what you're saying is
it's a 5 billion company and kind of
amazingly this was it was at 1.3 million
in funding to get to that 5 billion in
value is that right
yeah they basically only raised one
million dollars in funding and they got
that to 60 million arr they're probably
north of 100 million arr they're
probably worth their rest valued at five
they're probably worth 10 at this point
i mean it's like a crazy valuable
company that's insane they're growing
crazy you would need them to become a 25
to 50 billion dollar company and you're
betting that they can and will do that
yeah over the course of four or five
years when all your stock would vest yes
i think that
okay all right sounds good okay so uh
do you agree or disagree
uh
they've surprised me every step of the
way so far so you know when you first
it's like zapier i'd be like oh cool
indie hacker project and then it's like
no no it actually got to like a million
dollars aor it's like oh you know that's
cool cool bootstrap software company
maybe you can sell for 25 30 million
dollars
oh wow they're doing 50 million in aor
okay uh jeez what how many times again
am i gonna be wrong here so i'm just
debating do i really want to bet against
them again and i think the answer is no
i don't want to bet against them again
so i think i'm gonna give you
thumbs up on your on your on your one
here i would include it in sarah's list
flexport would you have given it the
thumbs up or thumbs down to be included
on sarah's list
can it be worth 50
yeah definitely
okay good so keep in mind we're keep in
mind we're talking about like five years
from today yeah five years exactly yeah
so
okay so we have two two successful
nominations to sarah's list i'd like to
give you my next domination you're gonna
hate this one or roll your eyes or
something okay
uniswap do you know what uniswap is no
oh my god that's insane to me okay so
uniswap uh if you go to like i don't
know because uniswap.org is how you get
to to the thing so you you know swap
what if i told you let's just play this
game there is a company in the
cryptocurrency space
and i have an opportunity for you to
join here's here's some of the things
you need to know about this
it is um it's bigger than deutsche bank
credit suisse and state street um all
combined it has um bigger in terms of
what current market cap and yeah in
terms of current market okay let me tell
you some other things about it oh is
that just market cap is that just one of
those crazy crypto market cap things
hold on let me just tell you a little
bit more what if i told you it has the
trading volume of coinbase with 50 times
less employees would that be something
you're interested in yes what if i told
you that this company is doing 10
billion a week in trading volume
and what if i told you it was doing that
with less than 35 employees
what if i told you that it took coinbase
eight years and a thousand employees to
get to a billion dollars in revenue and
tells you that uniswap is only two and a
half years old has less than 50
employees and is on pace to do over a
billion dollars in revenue this year
would that be something you're
interested in because that's unit swap
right now
in
so what do they do
so what do they do okay so let's say
you've heard of all the different like
um
tokens that exist so let's say have you
ever heard of um you know dye or
ethereum or whatever like yeah all these
different tokens right there's thousands
of thousands of different currencies so
coinbase what they're really good at is
to say you have us dollars you want to
go buy some bitcoin or ethereum you want
to go buy some you know some some solana
great um
we'll take your u.s dollars we'll
connect with your bank and you can buy
this crypto asset what uniswap does it
says thanks coinbase we'll take it from
here you're kind of slow and expensive
uh and you have you know you have all
these employees and all this red tape
and stuff like that from here once you
have a crypto token this is uniswap is
how you trade any crypto token for any
other crypto token so lets you swap
between any crypto asset instantaneously
and it's what's called a decentralized
exchange means
um there is no central company with a
bunch of employees that owns the
exchange it's a protocol that they built
um and all it does if you go to the
website it just says what currency do
you have what currency do you want
here's the the exchange rate push go and
it'll exchange it for you right there
and what they did was the genius of it
is
normally for a centralized exchange like
coinbase they have to have a you know
sort of they're the market maker they
they they find buyers and sellers and
they match them together and they have
to have you know certain amount of
reserves themselves to be able to
facilitate to bring liquidity into the
market
what what decentralized exchanges do
what dexes do that's that's what they're
called is you have a buyer you have a
seller and then you have this group in
the middle that i can also come in and
be a liquidity provider so i can just go
give uniswap some money
and i can earn a portion of the revenue
that they have that they make just by
providing liquidity into the pool oh
cool so they have it's like a
three-sided market and so they have like
um over 5 billion of liquidity that
users just locked up into their market
to create the liquidity for their
markets yeah it's like a it's like a
it's like a weird lending club type of
type of thing that's pretty sick only 30
people what type of person would be a
good tool wow what type of personality
would be good to work there
uh i don't know crazy nut i don't know
but you know
these types of things that it's like you
typically these are gonna be engineering
heavy like things and so you can come
and be you know do all the other stuff
so let's say you're a community person
you're a marketing person you're a pr
person you're whatever you can go and
sort of say look i have this skill set
that you probably need but when you're
at 35 people and this much scale they
kind of need everything they need more
of everything probably and so i think
anybody could probably fit in you just
think they uh how to solve some of their
problems do you think they give equity
yeah so basically
there's a company so there's a company
and then there's the the protocol the
company owns some of the tokens using
the protocol but um
like so so the company raised a series a
from andreessen horowitz and paradigm
and a bunch of others they raised only a
series a so i think they've only raised
11 million dollars to date and they've
reached basically the same scale as
coinbase on 11 million dollars and
coinbase is what a 80 billion dollar
company
so um so so i think you know this would
be a very very very valuable group to be
a part of now the economics are
different because it's crypto and
everything's weird it's like what's the
valuation what's my equity worth i don't
know it's all it's all funky you got to
figure it out yourself but there's
definitely enough value there so going
super fast it's kind of for a person
who's i imagine the personality type is
like someone who's okay with a little
bit a lot of chaos and some risk yeah
and like uh not non-traditional you're
okay with something that's
non-traditional
all right i'm gonna give you another
non-traditional one this this this might
be one of my stronger ones
so it's called uh andrew i think that's
how you say do you know what that is
i had it on my list all right you stole
it right off me wait did you really did
you really i didn't see it on yours
yes no it's not written up on here
oh sorry i didn't put my i have my own
little cheat sheet here that you don't
have all right great so mine's called
andrew so um i'll uh i'll tell you a
little bit background but you actually
might know a little bit more so
basically it started by the guy named
palmer lucky and the reason why this is
interesting is palmer lucky started
oculus when he was like 16 or 17 and
then he sold it to facebook for some
what like a billion dollars just like a
ton and it's interesting because palmer
lucky is very controversial so he's a uh
a big uh supporter of donald trump which
is very atypical in silicon valley he
was fired from facebook and a lot of
people or he was the one who said he
thinks he was fired because he liked
trump and he sued facebook for hundreds
of million and one so regardless if you
think that's cool or not he is
controversial amongst silicon valley
folks and so he started this company out
of orange county and they here's another
controversial thing they make stuff for
the government their first product was
an invisible wall basically so it was a
way to build drones i believe to keep uh
illegal immigrants from crossing the
mexican-american border so controversial
whatever we can we definitely can agree
to that they've raised money and it's
worth about 4.6 billion dollars they
have 510 employees this would not be
good for a liberal person or someone who
like you basically have to be moderate
or right of center to want to work here
uh palmer seems like a like a fine
enough guy a little quirky but
definitely it's a right-leaning company
um which isn't incredibly normal in
silicon valley i definitely think this
could be a palantir s company the way
that i describe what they do if i'm
correct is basically if you ever see the
movie war dogs people or the government
says we need blank and then people bid
and they wait to get it and then the
person they go we need some type of
vehicle that can fly like a plane but
land like a helicopter and then people
go out and build it well what andrew
does i believe is they build stuff that
they think the government needs and then
the government buys it from them and it
saves a bunch of time is that basically
what they do
yeah so they uh yeah exactly their their
primary revenue source comes from the
government and what they build is like
pretty fancy hardware software
combinations so they're like one of
their if you go to their websites like
sentry tower it's like this
solar-powered
tower it's like this giant pole that is
you know used to like you know
basically
monitor a border right monitor an area
and uh and it's autonomous and so
there's basically like the hardware to
be able to do that so like top flight
hardware mixed with software that makes
it like you know smart intelligent work
well you know it's like a nest camera
for the government and so you know they
have uh drones they have different
different things like that it's not a
huge product line because these things
are hard they probably take tens of
millions of dollars to make each one but
they um they're basically
trying to be the kind of like
the most technology forward provider for
you know the us defense budget which i
think is like you know hundreds of
billions of dollars i think is what you
have here like 700 billion dollars a
year
and the question is can so they're
currently worth a little bit over 4
billion they raise money from founders
fund i think can this company be worth
20 40 50 billion in five years 100 it
definitely can um it definitely can this
guy already built a billion dollar
company at the age of like 22 definitely
all right your turn
okay that's a good one i had that one on
my list so so i like that one a lot all
right sarah's list filling up we got uh
thumbs up there okay i'm gonna do one um
i'm gonna do one that i invested in
actually okay so disclaimer it's not
even really a disclaimer or disclosure
this is actually a flex yes i'm an
investor okay so this company is called
replit you ever seen replit do you know
what this does only because you have
been telling me for years it's going to
be the greatest
so um so i'll tell you how i found them
or how i kind of heard about them so i
heard about them from two different
places anytime these two people talk
about something you're like oh wait
that's like a winning combination so the
first is like my teenage nephew is like
using this tool replit to learn how to
code i'm like oh okay i've never heard
it before kind of like that's
interesting uh
stuff teenagers use you should probably
like pay attention to stuff teenagers
use because those tend to be big
companies you know whether it's snapchat
or you know
minecraft or roblox or things like that
and i was like all right so so yeah i
stashed it away didn't really pay too
much attention to it second time i heard
about it was from paul graham the
founder of y combinator he tweeted a
combination a graph of a hockey stick he
goes uh he said something you know like
one of the fastest girl you know this is
one of the fastest growing companies
i've ever seen he goes he's like this is
yes that's over 5 million users and that
may not sound like a lot but when your
users are all programmers 5 million is a
hell of a lot and um and that's so true
like five million programmers on a
network is like
worth its weight in gold
every programmer ever
yeah so and so then uh so i can't hear
too much about it but basically
companies value just under a billion
dollars right now so if you're looking
at this you're like okay can i
does this end up at five billion or more
what what's it do though what's it do so
what does it do okay you want to learn
how to code it's kind of like a sandbox
that does a few important things the
first is if you've ever tried have you
ever like gone down pathway like dude
i'm gonna learn how to code i'm gonna i
bought this udemy course i'm gonna learn
python have you ever like gone down that
path at all because
one of the most confusing things that
happens is you're like
oh where do i type this you don't
write your code in a google doc right
like you've got to type your code in a
code editor and like then it's like oh
great but you need to install these like
python packages you're like what the
hell's that it's like you need to like
install npm or like what the hell is npm
and then you're like it's like oh you
need to deploy so now you need servers
you're like server what do i get in one
of those and so it's all just very
confused just the environment which is
basically like the equipment you need to
code
setting up that developer environment in
itself is like for me was very confusing
now i'm like you know average person so
like if an average person finds it
confusing that means it's too confusing
and so what replied did was first they
were like dude look it's just a website
you go to it's already got all that
stuff baked in you don't have to install
anything you don't need five different
programs just to be able to deploy code
like you write the code here then you
push run you test it here and then you
push deploy and you deploy it here
great all built into one so that was
really useful for young hackers young
engineers and hobbyists who wanted to
like learn this stuff so the first thing
was they made all the stuff you need to
learn it then they were like okay cool
but this is kind of like a social
network because we got all these
programmers all writing code it's kind
of like if you've ever looked at github
github is this big network it's probably
the biggest network of developers and
they all put their code here well what
github did was like you could fork
something so you put some code you make
it publicly available i can read it and
then i could fork it make my own version
of it and you'll get notified that hey
sean remixed your thing
so riplet does that like on steroids so
they basically
it's almost like a game it's like all
the different programmers can see what
all the other programmers are doing they
can get inspired by those they can
literally take their code and remix it
make their own version of it or they can
like contribute to each other and they
could take little parts that somebody
made somebody made this bouncing ball
cool i'm gonna grab that i'll i don't
have to remake it from scratch i'll just
use their bouncing ball
program you know code and i'll add that
to my basketball hoop thing that i'm
making and so it's like a multi-player
little like game almost for programmers
to be able to like
not just not just write their code not
just deploy their code but also
you know like
find other pieces of code that they can
interact with and monetize it so you can
actually launch full apps full programs
on here and make money um it's like all
built in so
the bet here if you look at their graphs
it's like everything is a hockey stick
like crazy crazy upwards curve all right
i'm on board with that scale so so i
think that's
they do this side by side comparison
like here's our growth compared to
github's growth from your zero you're
one year two year three or four and
they're like outpacing github's growth
all right i'm on board with that i think
that's a good one um
can non-technical people apply there you
think of course right every technical
company definitely needs people that are
in non-technical roles whether it's
again marketing community sales whatever
whatever the roles will end up being um
yeah for sure and in fact usually those
companies technical companies get built
kind of like engineer first and so they
actually need people that are
non-technical to to be able to join
all right that's a good one um
i'm on board i'm on board with that one
um all right my turn uh this one is
similar to zapier air table so air table
is a is a microsoft excel alternative
it's a google sheet alternative when
they first came out i was like why on
earth why on earth would anyone need
this like google sheets works great and
then i used air table and they i
realized they're kind of making it their
own category it's very sticky it's very
neat right now they're valued uh since
2021 they raised money at a 5.7 billion
dollar valuation
i actually think they could be much
larger there's another company that i
kind of
compare them to they're not quite the
same but they're i think they're a
little bit stamp same in terms of
stickiness and that's and they came out
the same time uh or they got popular
around the same time that's monday.com
and they're worth they went public at
like 18 billion i think that airtable
could definitely do really great they
currently have 645 employees um
they the guy who started it i think his
name is howard liu
howie lou
and he's kind of like this prodigy
genius guy like that's like how they
stereotype him in the media but i've
seen interviews went to my tour he went
to duke did he
yeah
i saw interviews with him though he was
definitely like a prodigy young genius
but he was very like wise and like he
wasn't like a wacky weirdo he was like
pretty well thought uh
well spoken and you want to know
something funny yeah so seven years ago
so we were in a mastermind group if you
remember me you and a couple other guys
we used to get dinner every month or two
or something like that talk startups and
we would occasionally invite other
people in and so i have a dm where i
dm'd howie back when air table was very
you know it was was a lot smaller i
think it was still probably
i think it had just raised money maybe
under 100 million dollars i think was
the valuation at that point in time
and i was like howie you love airtable
think it's great i think it's
going to be big um you know you're a
fellow duke guy that's awesome hey i
host these mastermind dinners you should
come to one and he's like oh i'd love to
and we scheduled it
and uh you were scheduled to go to it
and then i think you and one other
person cancelled and like oh i can't
come and so i canceled the dinner and so
i never met him and like you know
who knows what could have been we could
have been homies by now we could have
been invested yeah a long time ago uh
you know under 100 million dollars did
you hang out with them no that was the
that was the excuse i had been i was
like
i do these as excuses to hang out with
people right i don't want to say hey i'd
love to meet you it's like yeah great
i don't love to meet you i don't want to
ask him to coffee but i was trying to
invite him to something cool he's like
hey we do this founder thing it's great
my bad howie i'm sorry dude
um all right so i have one
a yeah
yeah uh yay because excel is like the
there's this great quote which is like
every sas company you actually compete
with excel you don't compete with other
sas companies you compete with excel
because people just use excel for
everything and um
and so yeah i think that like i don't i
don't know what excel's market cap would
be but i think excel is more i don't
know what it would be dude excel is like
airpods to apple like yeah airpods would
be a 100 billion dollar company on its
own that's what excel is exactly so if
excel is a 100 billion dollar company i
think that the
the best threat to excel is going to end
up being worth you know 20 30
pretty i think there's a pretty good
chance of that and so i like this a lot
more it was recently at one or two
billion i liked it a lot more there than
at 5.7 but like you know
we didn't do the episode then we did it
now um so okay so i'll give you one
that's very very similar real quick
figma so figmas
too instead of you know and i'll do it
quick because people already know figma
but i would put it on the list uh
you know the way irritable airtable
airtable's doing for excel figma's doing
for photoshop so it's the younger
slicker cloud-based uh sexier
version of
design software and
it's kind of eating photoshop's lunch
i don't know worth now what is it seven
billion now it's like no it's uh so in
july of 2021 they raised 200 million
dollars at a 10 billion dollar vote uh
valuation but here's that sounds like a
lot but to the listeners and you sean
how much is uh what's
adobe's market cap so adobe uh
i believe almost all their revenue at
this point is from photoshop right
well it's the creative cloud which is
basically a bundle that you're like i
want photoshop to like but buy fireworks
and uh you know like buy all this other
that we like bundle in with
creative cloud okay so
tell me what you think it is
i would have guessed
um adobe's market cap is i don't know
150 billion or something like that what
what is it
uh it is
315. and if i'm not mistaken that might
be one of the
uh let's look it up it might be one of
the 50th let's see adobe would be would
is it's one of the biggest companies in
the world so adobe is the 30th largest
company in the world
so when you think about how big this can
be you think 10 billion dollars that's
so much money well adobe's the one of
the biggest companies in the world a
figma's going after it totally should be
on this list it's like it's like all the
business trends like first unbundling
it's like well creative cloud brings in
12 billion a year well let's unbundle
the most valuable part of it photoshop
and let's do it differently okay what's
different
second trend cloud-based right uh third
trend multiplayer right like when i'm
using figma my mouse is moving around
your mouse i'll also see what you're
doing on the same canvas that's really
cool right um and so they they're
they're piggybacking off all these like
kind of macro shifts and doing it right
just just sort of like by the way if you
think oh it's already at 10 billion
is it really going to 5x
last five years adobe has 6xed so adobe
was trading at 100 a share it's now at
660 a share in five years and that's at
adobe's large thing you know that's
their growth rate figma's growth rate
should be in the next five years much
faster than adobe's was in the last five
and um and so i think there's a fairly
good chance of that in fact i should
just go invest in all these companies uh
that are on this list this is this is a
great great list to be on
all right my turn uh so i agree i had to
think about mine so i completely agree
so we're about 100 so uh rippling that's
my next one rippling very boring company
i used it it's a payroll software
provider but it also manages devices and
gives you permissions to different stuff
so basically um if if you're a small
startup and people sign up to your to
work at your company it you i can easily
track which person has which computer
and i could pay software through there
and i can do hr management and issue
health care stuff to people why it's
interesting the founder his name's
what's his name parker conrad so he has
the controversial pass he started zenefs
which was at the time of the fastest
growing companies ever he got fired
because he kind of the culture was kind
of crazy people were like having sex in
the hallways and kind of being bro and
like that and so
he was like oh you know in order to do
this hr thing you have to like have this
like compliance training it takes 60
hours well cool here i just i created a
macro that will go through the training
for you just push the enter key every
you know five minutes or something like
that and you'll be done in six hours
instead of 60. like like that that
was a little bit like oh that's actually
like slightly illegal i think yeah but
the good news is he has experience the
also good news is that he up and
so you would think that you'd learn
because he got ousted so i kind of like
that i always like that in a company
where someone is like it's their second
time around and they've already been
mildly successful i think that's
actually a good thing they were here's
why i think this company's interesting
so they were last valued at 1 billion
1.3 billion dollars and i use them and
they're amazing i've used them for years
every company problem every company on
boards new employees and needs to get
their computer set up needs to get them
connected to all the systems
it's at every purse every company
problem and uh that's why it's kind of
genius
and there uh so workday which is in the
space is worth 67 billion dollars
paychecks which is a uh just a payroll
provider it's worth 40 billion dollars
so
i don't think that this their valuation
is still true
their own category which is why it's
even better like if you said does
rippling end up i think rippling if it's
at a billion now i think it's maybe one
of the best candidates uh
to like 50x on this list right it's one
of those that like you know when square
went public square republic at like i
think three billion or two billion
valuations else like 150. now it's like
100 so
square after it ipoded which was again
d-risk d-risk d-risk now it's liquid
it's already had like a 30-40 x since
then um and so that's like wow that's
you get some insane appreciation on your
on your stock and so i think rippling is
one that if you told me this 30 to 50
x's i'd say of the things we've said on
this list that might be the number one
candidate so far
all right so then uh we're we're we've
got a hit and when i use the product
it did everything well but it was still
pretty clunky so i think a lot of your
product designer if your customer
support sales i think these guys are
hiring for a bunch of different stuff so
that's my pick all right your turn
okay uh i'm gonna do one that's a little
by the way i think
these are hits i think
yeah i think so too um all right so so
here's one open store you know what
openstore is
uh it's new isn't it it's new okay so uh
this might not this might not this might
well no this might hit but this might be
too early but go ahead
yeah so okay so
what is this um
so first let me say who's the founder so
the founder is is two kind of
powerhouses now i don't know how much of
their time they're spending on this but
one is keith or boy who was the ceo at
square he was part of the paypal mafia
he's a big-time vc he's a total dick on
twitter entertaining dude i i enjoy he's
very smart and he's an on
twitter uh which i find to be hilarious
and then this other guy um
jack abraham jack abraham was kind of
like wonder kid built a company sold it
to ebay pretty early on uh was like kind
of a hot shot at paypal spun out and he
has his own like studio and so they
together came together and they made um
they made open store which is a riff off
of keith or boy's other pre last company
that's now worth five billion dollars
open door so what open door did was you
want to sell your house
don't go through the whole like dog and
pony show i will buy your house now you
don't have to stage it you don't have to
fix it up you don't have to hire an
agent you don't have to do anything just
sell me the home i'll just give you a
price right now and you can sell it
today so i give you liquidity in this
house market instantaneous sales
open store is the same thing for
e-commerce they're saying you want to
sell your e-commerce company i'll buy
your shopify store right now you don't
have to go through the whole banker
process make a dag do do all this stuff
i'll just plug into your data and i'll
just give you an offer right now and so
what they're trying to do is roll up
shopify stores and so they're they
raised i think their first round maybe
was was at a 250 million dollar
valuation so to get your 5x here
you have to bet that it becomes a
billion dollar company with this guy's
track record square open door with jack
abraham's track record it's a very good
shot that they sent up
being being worth more more than a
billion dollars
this space is very hot so do you know
thracio that we've talked about before
it's the one that thoracio was
was was the first hot company that was
rolling up amazon businesses businesses
that sell products only on amazon
they're called fba fulfilled by amazon
companies and uh they rolled them all up
do you know what thoracio's valued at
right now what it's like 510. they're
gonna go public at a 10 billion dollar
valuation i think they might be the
fastest company to a 10 billion dollar
exit um ever i think i think they're
like they're three years old they're
four years old three years old and you
know very capital efficient how they
went there because they used a lot of
debt to buy these companies because the
company's already are profitable or
producing a lot of revenue so they're
able to use big debt to do this and so
open store is doing the same thing
without the amazon style it's for
shopify and so i think that this model
this open store model is one of the
fastest
easiest and fastest ways to build a
billion dollar company and i think that
this company at 250 million i see a lot
of value in this pick here yes it could
go to zero this could also not work this
has higher risk than the other stuff on
this of this list so that's the that's
the disclaimer it's much higher risk but
i think the reward is a lot higher here
too okay so this
i agree this could 10x
this borderline wouldn't be considered
part of the list because
no it's because they just launched
they're they're it's a year or less
right it's july 15 2021. so this
wouldn't fit in the category of being
like a cushy gig
but
i i i i'm cool with adding it but yeah i
think i think it might be on the like
hey you're on you're you're in the the
batter's box you're not on the batter's
box you're in the on deck circle right
we're just waiting for you to mature you
got to season up a little bit in order
to be on this list given the criteria of
the list also but we could swap it so
keith boy has another company that's
incredibly interesting i believe it's
called fair
f-a-i-r-e-i
he's just an investor in that one
yeah i didn't add it to the list but
it's a wholesale marketplace for
retailers and brands so you could just
basically uh
it's almost like it's a database
but i used it recently
for my brand i was like oh yeah we
should sell wholesale too i was like
okay so what am i gonna do go contact
every
brick and mortar store and say hey would
you like to carry my brand my online
brand and your store it's a good brand
here's the details here's my catalog i
made it in in excel and i have to update
it weekly and then here's my pricing and
then here i just go to my shopify store
and just buy some stuff like it's like
you have to string together five tools
to set up wholesale fare is basically
like you want wholesale list yourself as
a company the brick and mortar stores
can all like just choose to to buy from
you your catalog is stored here it just
takes for that whole problem i think
it's like a 15 billion dollar company
yeah i don't know if that can
10x but it's doing really well and i
didn't do research on it for this pr
project but i've uh
i tell people if they want to look
whenever people ask me this question of
where they should join i say that
company sounds incredibly interesting
um all right we'll do maybe one last one
yeah one last time
on yourself all right i'm gonna do one
that i also i'm an investor in this one
so i'm
there's a disclosure it's called next
health and the reason why i think it's
cool it's basically the very simple
dumbed-down version it's almost like
shopify for doctors so basically when
you go to a doctor you have to fill out
a form and they've automated the form so
you just fill it out online but then if
every other doctor uses the same uses
next health all your information is on
that platform and so it's much easier so
you have basically one medical record
and also they've opened it up to
third-party developers who can build
apps using your health data and your
like uh
your whole health record and you can see
uh interesting stuff an example a very
tiny example is if you're on smile
direct club and you want to find out
where an orthodontist is nearby who
could fit you for your orthodontist they
say hey next here's all the doctors in
next health that are in that network
just click here you're good to go and
that's like a third party app that
whatever they are worth 500 million
dollars their ceo is young 26 27 i've
gotten dinner with him he basically has
told me
and i don't exactly remember how he said
it but he was like yeah i kind of want
to take over the world like he he was
like i i've i thought
yeah he was like yeah he was like well i
think he's i think he told me his his
parents are from bangladesh and i think
he goes you know bangladesh is an
interesting country because it has a
really large male population and it has
a low unemployment rate so if i wanted
to take over the world i think i could
go there and rally the young men and we
could build our own army and i think
that'd be a good place like like he had
this like well thought out and i was
like you're nuts i love you i'm id so
next health is interesting to me and
they've raised uh
150 million dollars i think and so it's
big enough that they uh maybe they've
only raised 50 million dollars it's big
enough that it's a little bit uh settled
and they can pay well
right
all right you want to bring it home you
bring it home with one
one one that one that's a little bit
unorthodox i think we said a lot of
popular names uh here's an unpopular
name one trust so one trust is a company
that specializes in making your company
gdpr compliant
and oh my god the most boring on
earth valued at five billion dollars um
you know you have to you have to sort of
endlessly keep up with privacy laws uh
are different in all these different
countries if gdpr for europe us is going
to have their own version of this other
country's gonna have their own version
of this and they're always gonna evolve
and um and they have the customers and
they're going to basically continue to
service these customers and for the
companies you have huge huge risk
because it's like if you're not
compliant on gdpr it's like fines that
are like you know multiplied per user or
something like that it's like your fines
can be exorbitant and nobody wants to
deal with this nobody wants to become an
expert of this nobody wants to throw
huge amounts of engineering and design
and and policy uh head count towards
doing this it's going to be much easier
to like buy a solution and pay for pay
for somebody else as your cover your ass
insurance to take care of your gdpr
needs i think it's one of the fastest
growing companies in the country right
now it's called one trust i think
they're based in atlanta if i'm right um
i might be mixing them up with another
one there's actually two companies that
are both billion dollar companies in
this space i love these companies i want
to invest in these companies and if i
you know was going to send send somebody
to go work at one of the work at a
company that has this profile this would
be one of them so i think it's a good
contender for sarah's list
all right i think um i think that's the
list that's
i i think
i think this is this to do a listener
applying to jobs this could be one of
the most life-changing episodes
uh this is good i think this is a really
interesting idea when we when i i used
to have this product called just jobs
where i would write companies that do
this and i would pay users to people
would pay to have access to it this is
going to become maybe a recurring
segment we'll see this is pretty
interesting well i told you the thing i
wanted to do with this was i'm going to
curate 50 companies that meet this
criteria
and i'm going to basically create a job
board from this and the the thing with
the job board is you can't just be a
company who wants to come
list on here no only these 50 companies
that are curated can post on this job
board uh they have to pay to do it but
but but if they don't pay they're just
on the list but no jobs will show up and
so i want to have a running job so we
take this segment idea uh but basically
the reason i had a bunch of these
companies listed is because me and ben
have been cooking up oh we should launch
a job board and when we launch a job
board what would add some value well if
i could curate companies that i think
people should work for this is not an
original idea i think you did something
like this there's just a bunch of people
have done things like this curated
companies that you think are cool and
you turn that into a product and so
we're gonna do that with a job board
pretty soon uh we'll launch that pretty
soon with pallet
sick well that's freaking awesome good
episode
all right man i gotta run
[Music]
let's travel never looking back